selecciona todas las relaciones
descritas por la siguiente ecuación y es
igual a siete octavos de equis y me dan
opción a b c y d vamos a analizarla es
caso por caso un ramo de ocho rosas
cuesta siete pesos en flores de flora
supongo que esta es una florería
extremadamente barata un ramo con 12
rosas cuesta 11 pesos la ecuación
describe la relación entre el número de
rosas x y su precio en flores de flora y
bien para verificar esto vamos a hacer
una pequeña tabla en la que voy a
comparar el número de rosas x contra el
precio que tienen en flores de flora y
contra el valor de la ecuación igual a 7
octavos de x entonces aquí voy a poner
siete octavos de
bien entonces cuánto vale esto pues
veamos si yo compro 7 perdón 8 rosas si
yo compro 8 rosas en flores de flora me
cuesta 7 pesos un ramo con 8 rosas
cuesta 7 pesos pero cuánto vale 7
octavos de x pues 7 octavos de x sería 7
octavos de 8 los 8 se cancelan y me
queda 7 por lo tanto al menos para este
caso si es cierto que yo es igual a 7
octavos de x pero qué pasa si yo compro
12 rosas si yo compro 12 rosas entonces
debería pagar 11 pesos en flores de
flores pero cuánto vale 7 octavos de 12
7 octavos de 12 pues esto es lo mismo
que 7 por 3 he vivido todo entre 4 7 por
3 entre 2 me hago tantito hacia acá 7
por 3 entre 2 que cuánto es 7 por 3 es
21 entre 2 sería 10.5 10.5 no es lo
mismo que 11 por lo tanto estas dos
cosas son distintas
de modo que la opción a no puede ser
correcta puesto que ya no siempre es
igual a siete octavos de x
qué hay de la opción b hay un descuento
del 12.5 por ciento en cada artículo de
la tienda jose el loco
la ecuación describe la relación entre
el precio de un artículo antes del
descuento x y su precio tras aplicar el
descuento y bien entonces tenemos este
porcentaje tenemos un descuento del 12.5
por ciento
ahora el 12.5 por ciento de algún
artículo 12.5 por ciento lo puede
escribir en términos de una fracción
como
12.5 entre 100
12.5 de cada 100 pero esto es lo mismo
que si multiplico todo por 10 125 entre
mil
125 entre 1000 pero cuánto es 125 entre
1000 pues todo es divisible entre 125
por lo tanto ha divido el numerador y el
denominador por 125 obtengo 1 entre 8
por lo tanto a cada artículo le voy a
rebajar una octava parte de su precio de
modo que el artículo si tiene un precio
original x qué es estoy diciendo aquí
antes del descuento tiene un precio x
entonces después del descuento va a
tener un precio de x menos el descuento
aplicado a x pero el descuento es de un
octavo el precio por lo tanto sería x
menos un octavo de equis y esto
simplemente sería
siete octavos de equis pero lo que estoy
haciendo aquí es aplicar el descuento
por lo tanto que tengo que ya que es el
precio después del descuento es igual a
siete octavos de x de modo que ve si es
correcta ve si es correcta muy bien
vamos con se la entrada a un campo de
coche a cuestas siete pesos e incluye
ocho municiones cada munición adicional
cuesta un peso la ecuación describe la
relación entre el número de municiones x
y el precio pagado y bueno el goya es
este juego en el que vas a un campo y
las disparas bolas de pintura a tus
amigos entonces lo que me están diciendo
es que la entrada al campo para poder
jugar cuesta siete pesos e incluye ocho
municiones de nuevo vamos a hacer una
tablita por aquí así como lo hicimos
para la opción nada vamos a poner el
número de municiones x
precio pagado
y de nuevo vamos a poner siete octavos
de x
qué es el valor contra el que queremos
comparar allí
vamos a ver
si hago mi tablita así entonces tengo
que
si tengo ocho municiones entonces pagué
siete pesos para entrar al campo y de
nuevo puedo verificar que siete octavos
de x en este caso es lo mismo que siete
octavos por ocho los ocho se cancelan y
me queda siete por lo tanto jesse es y
aceptamos de equis para este caso ahora
cada munición adicional cuesta un peso
entonces si yo tuviera nueve municiones
o si íbamos a hacer nueve municiones
nueve municiones entonces yo debería
haber pagado ocho pesos
de modo que es cierto que 8 es siete
octavos por nueve pues veamos siete
octavos por xx ahorita vale nueve
entonces por nueve y esto cuánto va a
ser pues siete por nueve 63 entre 8 y 8
por 8 64 por lo tanto esto es tantito
menos que 8 esto es menor que 8 pero
entonces este número y y este número de
aquí no pueden ser iguales de modo que
esta relación tampoco es cierta vamos a
tachar la tampoco es cierta la de sin
perdón la c
finalmente la ecuación corresponde a la
gráfica a continuación y me dan esta
gráfica de aquí
esta gráfica pues vamos a ver cuando x
vale 0
la relación recuerden que estoy tratando
de pensar en la relación de igual a 7
octavos de x
siete octavos de x entonces si x vale
cero que también vale cero por lo tanto
el punto cero cero debería estar en la
gráfica y si lo está y cuando x vale 8
cuando x vale 8 entonces tengo que ya es
igual a
siete octavos
por 8 los 8 se cancelan
y me queda 7 por lo tanto cuando x vale
8 ya debe valer 7
es este punto aquí que si está sobre 7
por lo tanto estos dos puntos están en
la gráfica y esta gráfica así describe
la relación proporcional que nos dan por
lo tanto las opciones que yo diría son
correctas son la opción b y la opción d